es soll nicht mehr sagen was ist ohne
wird sollte das ist jetzt die
zusammenfassung von dem frank boss kanal
prank broß game master videos sind
kasperletheater auf youtube den leuten
willkommen zu einem neuen video freut
mich dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt
ich habe direkt mal eine frage an euch
und zwar wusstet ihr dass es auf youtube
mehr als einen rebecca viewing gibt es
wirklich so auf diesen mit tausenden
kanal der prinzipiell eins zu eins für
ihn jetzt bin ich gekommen weil er in
einem meiner letzten videos aufgetaucht
ist und bei dem kein master video bereit
das ist übrigens mittlerweile wieder
online leute ganz kurzes update noch
dazu bevor wir anfangen ich habe nachdem
das video gesperrt wurde einfach aus
heiterem himmel habe ich beschwerde
eingelegt bei youtube und gesagt leute
das darf nicht gesperrt werden zwei tage
später youtube dann so sebastian du hast
recht das darf wirklich nicht gesperrt
werden ist wieder frei geschaltet sei
das system also der vermeintliche
rechteinhaber hat das video erst mal
sperren lassen und dann kriegst zwei
tage lang keine klicks und ich lasse es
dann überprüfen und dann findest du
brauchst ja da ist kein
urheberrechtsverstoß cool was ist mit
den zwei tagen an klicks die verpasst
habe
geil auf jeden fall leute ich bin ich
leider umlagern es geht um die frank
rost im heutigen video weil die post und
wirklich also wenn ich nicht besser
wissen würde wenn man gesichter hier
passieren würde
es ist wirklich einfach eins zu eins von
becker ring in männlich und zu zweit
auch mein absolutes fable video von dem
was wir heute anschauen werden ist
alleine mit game master im schwimmbad
ihr seht hier leute es ist wirklich die
absolute krönung also die erste sache
die man reden muss wenn man sich die
projektors anschaut sind diese vom nails
bis die leute wenn ich oder meine
freunde ich auf den typen youtube video
aufnehmen dann sie wie immer so ok bei
der aufnahme schon wir müssen aufpassen
okay wie müssen sich positionieren damit
es am ende ein gutes signal also eine
anzeige bild was vor dem video es gibt
und es muss alles jetzt in der aufnahme
stimmen weil nachher was verschiedenen
photoshop sodass voll scheiße kinos
überhaupt nicht dieses schwimmbad
vermeldet sie sind einfach in so einer
rutsche
wir haben einfach so eine so einen
schwarzen umriss reingeschoben photoshop
haben sie ein neues maß geringe
photoshop und den roten kreis das ist
dann das thumbnail also man muss vorweg
sagen heute es gibt so viele videos von
crankos die es verdient hätten dass man
da mal genauer hinschaut unter anderem
auch hier haare schneiden am
schlechtesten friseur das ist ja es ist
quasi ein citybike wien hat den make up
artist gefaked die printbranche den
friseurbesuch weil das ist wirklich fett
weg wenn ich mir das mal anschauen
sollte und in die kommentare reichen
aber jetzt starten wir mit dem video
alleine mit game master im schwimmen
weiter ich will jetzt wissen hat der
game master in fucking sixpack oder
nicht alter leute unter vertrag ist und
erst recht ein getrenntes über ein tor
wir sind so wir haben drei tage um 222
okay also das video fängt so an die post
stehen und die küche glaube ich habe nie
so einen tresor den haben sie natürlich
vom game master bekommen und dann öffnen
sie diesen tresor und in diesem tresor
ist dann natürlich ein hinweis von game
master wo sie als nächstes hingehen
sollen kommt kommt ins schwimmbad kommt
in schwimmbach macht alles soweit
komplett sind also haben den hinweis und
game master bekommen dass sie jetzt ins
schwimmbad gehen sollen weiß ich nicht
ganz verstanden warum sie den namen des
schwimmbads zensieren also wenn man
einmal die kommentare schaut findet man
sehr schnell heraus und welches jahren
ist hier zum beispiel ist der brite
kommentar von oben das schwimmbad heißt
aquarius plettenberg moment war jetzt
fällt mir ja was ein vielleicht haben
dies in dem video zensiert weil sie
keine drehgenehmigung hatten im pc markt
aufzunehmen was sinn macht weil allein
wenn man sich schon so die fans von den
raptors anschaut so die chance uns
einfach hin sodass den egal natürlich
holen sie sich keine drehgenehmigung
einführen wie die haben keine
drehgenehmigung wollen deswegen nicht
dass zuschauer von ihnen auf das
schwimmbad kommen und da vielleicht
nachfragen so hey die waren ja bei euch
und das schimmert dann sieht moment mal
den bei uns gefilmt und die dann bastert
ok deswegen sieht alles klar also dann
sind sie unterwegs sollten anstatt das
so sagen so jung wie fangen es los und
dann schnitt okay wir sind da nein
die talk die machen einfach so spannende
musik dröhnte und kommentieren drei
minuten
einfach so aufnahmen von der landschaft
gibt es okay gut ist eine felsmann ja
okay ihr könnt auch immer ein wie das
machen was ihr wollt aber ich frage mich
was die zuschauer so denken in dem
moment so alt krank die felswand deger
das habe ich noch nie gesehen
stell dir vor der gamers meist an felsen
runter ohne wird die leute auf so eine
seltsame art und weise ist groß schon
schon entertainment es ist nicht ganz
das gleiche wie rebecca ringbeck ohrring
ist das so bisschen mehr so
das ist so richtig so mehr abstoßen
frank rost auch schon krank 3 ist
gefaked aber man kann mehr so darüber
lachen wie es gefällt das weißt du
wirklich so richtig stupide ist stets
weiterhin sie sind dann endlich mal im
schwimmbad angekommen und gebt euch
jetzt mal diese szenen okay schaut euch
diese szene an und danach teile ich euch
eine theorie die ich über die frank boss
habe mit leute wir sind drin
da hast du heute hier um rennt wird
sagen wir zehn achtet man auf die
betonung von der art und weise wie
sprechen in dieser situation und achte
darauf ihre mimik so also ich das video
zum ersten mal gesehen habe und dieses
video hier vorzubereiten habe ich mir
bei dieser szene gedacht moment mal ich
bekomme hier gerade ein sehr sehr
seltsam eindruck die bank groß fehlten
auch ihre videos richtig dreist haben
wir schon raus kunden wenn wir auch
gleich noch mal weitersehen
aber ich glaube anders als bei rebecca
ring wissen die prank brust selbst wie
dämlich das ist was sie da machen und
machen sich schon während sie das video
aufnehmen darüber lustig also vexeo.de
prekär sind so mal schauen wir hier so
rumläuft und das mal an ich bin gespannt
wer hier rumrennt so wie er das sagt das
ist doch ironisch gemeint das ist
ironisch gemeint wollte safe co also ich
bekomme da den ein und das projekt muss
ich denken so dh es kann eigentlich
nicht sein dass dieses seltsame zeug was
wir da auf youtube machen erfolgreich
ist so wir können uns auch nicht selbst
ernst nehmen wenn wir das machen und
deswegen gehen wir uns gar nicht mehr im
video die mühe so zu akten als würde es
ernst meinen aber was was selbst hören
uns nicht mehr mühe geben es zu faken
und uns beim faken über uns selbst
lustig machen weil wir wissen wie du
musst ist checken es unsere zuschauer
immer noch nicht dass es fähig ist
also warum mehr mühe geben warum nicht
schon bei der aufnahme über sich selbst
lachen
heute früh ist es ruhig wir gucken haben
die ganz verbergen einem 78 ja bis jetzt
sehen wir noch gar nicht so dass viele
rutschen
ok also praxis im schwimmbad drin und
jetzt beginnt dieser partie nicht eben
schon beschrieben habe also die szene wo
sie quasi dann in badehose oberkörper
frei da sitzen die ist bei minute 5 und
16 sekunden circa und das ist sie
wirklich fünf minuten lang gar nichts
zum thema game master riestedt leute in
einem video was alleine mit game master
im schwimmbad heißt passiert einfach von
-5 bis -10 nichts zum game master und
sie fühlen sich einfach dabei wie sie
rutschen rutschen als legende dicker
aber dann leute dann dann tochter game
master auf das ist wirklich leute also
sowas kann man sich nicht ausdenken die
jetzt erscheint der game master der game
master erscheint ist ja und ich weiß
nicht warum aber sie haben sich
scheinbar nicht nur die mühe gemacht so
die originale game master diese enorme
muss maske zu besorgen
es ist einfach so das gesicht von
irgendwo im alten mann
wo ist der sinn leute wenn ihr schon
game master videos macht solltet ihr
dann nicht wenigstens so die game master
maske auch wirklich dabei haben also
dieser muskel scheinbar nicht also es
ist schon weg aber es ist irgendwo auch
lustig wie sieht die praxis einfach so
komplett auf alles scheiße okay selbst
wenn sie ein video fähigen und so tun
als wäre der game master im schwimmbad
mache die sich nicht mal die mühe die
richtige maske zu besorgen
die chance einfach komplett auf alles
und ihre zuschauer die keine ahnung drei
jahre alte pflegefälle sind also jetzt
nur des bäckers zuschauern aber wer so
was er nimmt also schon klar die regen
sich nicht mehr darüber auch
was mag
heute müssen wir forschen wie das
aufgenommen haben also die haben irgend
ein kumpel von sich gefragt so hague wir
wollen nicht schon wieder nerven aber
kann es vielleicht nochmal den game
master spielen in unserem video
also leute respekt aber ich glaube man
muss wirklich sechs jahre alt sein um
das ernst zu nehmen was sie bringt was
ihr machen
gebt euch die nächste einbindung von
gamers at ist auch dass der knüller
also sie laufen hoch zu dieser rutsche
und dann ist er ein symbol der ist ja
gerade darin sodann gehe zu rutschen
film so kurz aus versehen in die rutsche
rain man sieht dass da niemand ist was
sie dann machen ist sie nehmen also eine
halbe sekunde einblendung von wie sie
für ihren kumpel dann wahrscheinlich 5
minuten später dahin gesetzt haben ob
man die rutsche und so nahe an seinem
gesicht gesagt haben das ist das was ich
gerade ihr seht und machen so ein schock
soundeffekt dahinter und das ist es dann
nicht unbedingt die klügste entscheidung
oder wartet mal leute das hier ist die
person die die maske auf hat ne moment
mal ich frage mich gerade hat man an
irgendeiner stelle beide prangt groß und
die person die den game master spielt
zusammen im bild gesehen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich glaube ich
nicht
[Musik]
sieht man sich auch an der stelle nicht
okay dann habe ich eine neue theorie die
haben nicht mal einen kumpel dabei
sondern die haben das zu zweit gefegt
wie hast du zwei effekt man sieht er
mich hier von der aufnahme wo sie noch
zusammen da sind zudem schwenken wo man
auch einmal diese person mit der maxime
sich da ist ein schnitt dazwischen und
wenn er von dieser person wieder
zurückgeht auf die beiden ist noch mal
ein schnitt dazwischen
also meine theorie ist haben sich nicht
mal ein kumpel mitgenommen etwas zu
faken sondern haben sich einfach einen
entspannten tag im schwimmbad gemacht
haben sich dann fünf minuten genommen um
diese zwei game master szenen zu faken
nicht mal eine dritte person mit dabei
und das wird dann 2,3 millionen aufrufe
gebracht ja das ist youtube deutschland
man denkt jetzt fangen wir später
nochmals zehn leute das ist dann jetzt
so eine rutsche mit sonar falltüren die
so nach unten weg hätten dann fällt man
und es ist wieder nur einer von den
beiden im bild zu sehen also einer
steten dieser rutsche das ist glaube ich
der ist dass das major oder kellerwände
ja eigentlich sollte es eigentlich
wissen aber ich weiß es nicht
[Musik]
und wenn dann der eine rutsche steht hat
sich der andere die wieder die maxi
aufgezogen und guckt hinten dann so in
dieses bild soll ich mal sagen das ist
ohne wird es heute das ist die
zusammenfassung von dem frank boss kanal
prank broß game master videos sind
kasperletheater auf youtube ohne scheiß
es ist das ist kasperletheater eins zu
eins ich sage euch warum einerseits weil
das so konnten ist der sich an
grundschulkinder richtet oder an leute
mit der geistigen reife von
grundschulkindern andererseits weil ich
das okay als wir diesen vermeintlichen
game master dahin
das ist einfach kasperletheater ihr
kennt doch alle diese szenen oder also
vorne ist so irgend guter kalt her und
von hinten kommt und böse an
oder ist ganz publikum herr hinter dir
ist jemand hinter de ist jemand das ist
das gros sind youtube kasperletheater
effekt es gibt also
wir gucken da rüber ich da wir ja leute
wenn ihr noch eine analyse von youtube
kasperltheater haben wollt dann schreibt
mir das geld den kommentare lassen
bewertung auf diesem video da und jacky
trüben einen vorstand ist wie gehabt das
zu mir ich küsse aber augen macht's gut